This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. All parents have moments when their kids test their patients. Lian Yang is no exception. I often yell at my kids for things that they did by accident, like spilling a smoothie or leaving a cap off of a permanent marker and, you know, making black permanent stains all over the sofa. When this happens and the couches covered in black splotches or they're smoothie on the floor, the perpetrators inevitably offer this defense.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。所有父母都会遇到孩子考验他们耐心的时刻。莉安·杨也不例外。我经常因为孩子们无意中做的事对他们大吼大叫，比如洒了冰沙，或者忘盖永久性马克笔的笔帽，你知道的，把整个沙发弄得全都是黑色的永久性污渍。每当发生这种事，沙发上布满了黑色的斑点，或者地板上洒满了冰沙时，肇事者难免会这样辩解。
It was an accident. It's not my fault. I didn't mean to do it. I shouldn't say this but I tell them it doesn't matter that you didn't mean to do it. I shouldn't say this, but I tell them it doesn't matter that you didn't mean to do it. What matters is that you won't do it again. Leanne's reaction while understandable is deeply ironic. She's a psychologist who studies how we read other people's intentions. We need to think about other people's minds in order to figure out who our friends are,
这不是故意的。不是我的错。我不是有意的。我不该这么说，但我告诉他们，你不是有意的这并不重要。我不该这么说，但我告诉他们，你不是有意的这并不重要。重要的是你不会再犯了。莉安的反应虽然可以理解，但却具有极大的讽刺意味。她是一位心理学家，专门研究我们如何解读他人的意图。我们需要思考其他人的心思，以便弄清楚谁是我们的朋友，
who to avoid, whom to punish, whether to punish, and we need to read people's intentions in any ordinary interaction, like having a conversation and figuring out what to say and how to respond. As we go through life, we are constantly making sense of people's actions by interpreting their intentions. Our ability to read what is happening in other people's minds is like an invisible compass guiding us through life. But sometimes it leads us astray.
该避开谁，该惩罚谁，是否应该惩罚，并且我们需要在任何日常互动中解读人们的意图，比如进行对话并弄清楚该说什么以及如何回应。在人生的旅途中，我们不断地通过诠释他人的意图来理解他们的行为。我们解读他人内心活动的能力就像一个无形的指南针，指引我们走过一生。但有时它会把我们引入歧途。
We misread other people's intentions, especially when we are hurt or angry. This week on Hidden Brain, how our powers of observation allow us to navigate our social worlds until they don't. It's the start of a series we're calling Mind Reading 2.0. It explores a topic listeners have asked us about a lot. How to decode what's going on in other people's heads? We are constantly trying to read other people's minds. When we interact with friends, relatives and co-workers, we ask ourselves, what is going on in this other person's head?
我们会误读他人的意图，尤其是当我们受伤或愤怒时。本周的《Hidden Brain》，我们的观察力如何让我们在社交世界中自如穿梭，直到它们失效。这是我们称之为“读心术2.0”系列节目的开端。它探讨了一个听众经常向我们询问的话题：如何解码别人脑子里在想什么？我们不断地试图揣摩别人的心思。当我们与朋友、亲戚和同事互动时，我们会问自己：这个人的脑子里到底在想什么？
What is she want? What are his intentions? Our ability to read other minds involves an extraordinary feat of cognition, yet it mostly unfolds in our heads without us being aware of it. Minus the skill, the simplest of interactions would be mired in confusion and misunderstanding. Leanne Young is a psychologist and neuroscientist at Boston College. She has spent years studying this mental ability and the profound effects it has on our lives. Leanne Young, welcome to Hidden Brain.
她想要什么？他的意图是什么？我们阅读他人内心世界的能力涉及一项非凡的认知壮举，然而它主要在我们的脑海中展开，而我们甚至没有意识到这一点。如果没有这项技能，最简单的互动也会陷入混乱和误解。莉安·杨是波士顿学院的心理学家和神经科学家。她花费多年时间研究这种心理能力以及它对我们生活的深远影响。莉安·杨，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。
Thanks so much, it's good to be here, Shankar. I want to start with a very simple example that shows how important it is for us to read what's happening in the minds of other people. In the 1993 movie Mrs. Doubtfire starring Robin Williams, the character's Daniel and Miranda have split up, and Daniel comes up with this unconventional way to win Miranda back. He returns to the house in disguise as Mrs. Doubtfire, an elderly widow who seeks a role of nanny and housekeeper. Now, he quickly wins the trust of the family. Very soon, Miranda is asking Mrs. Doubtfire for life advice, including whether to go on a date where the
非常感谢，很高兴来到这里，尚卡尔。我想从一个非常简单的例子开始，它展示了解读他人内心活动对我们来说有多么重要。在1993年由罗宾·威廉姆斯主演的电影《窈窕奶爸》中，由他饰演的角色丹尼尔和米兰达离婚了，丹尼尔想出了这个非常规的办法来重新赢得米兰达的芳心。他乔装打扮成“道格菲太太”回到家中，这是一位寻找保姆和管家职务的老寡妇。很快，他就赢得了这个家庭的信任。不久之后，米兰达就开始向道格菲太太征求生活建议，包括是否要去和那个
man she's just met. Mrs. Doubtfire, let me ask you a question. Oh, sir. How long after Mr. Duffer passed away, Winston, did you feel any desire? Never. Never. Never again. Never again.
她刚刚认识的男人约会。道格菲太太，我能问你个问题吗？哦，先生。在杜夫先生去世后，温斯顿，你过了多久才感到有任何欲望？从不。从不。绝不。绝不再有。
Once the father of your children is out of the picture, the only solution is total and lifelong celibacy. Cellimacy? Yes. picture. The only solution is total and lifelong celibacy. So, Leanne, if we lack the capacity to read what was happening inside the minds of Daniel and Miranda, how would that change how we understood this scene? Well, I think we wouldn't be able to appreciate the humor and the irony in that scene where Daniel is essentially, he knows what is going on with his wife and he is trying to get his wife to not date this other man. And of course, we know that the wife doesn't know Daniel's true identity as Daniel.
一旦你孩子的父亲从你的生活中消失了，唯一的解决办法就是彻底且终身的独身。独身？是的。画面。唯一的解决办法就是彻底且终身的独身。所以，莉安，如果我们缺乏解读丹尼尔和米兰达内心活动的能力，这将如何改变我们对这一场景的理解？嗯，我想我们将无法体会那个场景中的幽默和讽刺，在那个场景中，丹尼尔基本上很清楚他妻子的情况，他正试图让他妻子不要跟这个别的男人约会。当然，我们知道妻子并不知道丹尼尔的真实身份就是丹尼尔。
She thinks that he is this housekeeper and we know that she doesn't know. And so there's this very sort of layered understanding that we need to have as the audience to find the scene funny. Yeah. We can't find it funny without realizing that she doesn't know what he knows and then who he is. Right. So we're able to read in some ways that he has an agenda here because he wants to
她以为他是这个管家，而我们知道她并不知道。因此，作为观众，我们需要有这种非常有层次感的理解，才能觉得这个场景很有趣。是的。如果我们没有意识到她不知道他知道什么以及他是谁，我们就无法觉得它好笑。对吧。所以我们在某种程度上能够看出他在这里有一个意图，因为他想
keep his wife from dating other men. And we also understand that she doesn't know what's going on. But what's interesting to me, Leanne, is that we entue all of this effortlessly. No one sits down as they're watching the movie and actually says to themselves, all right, this is who, what's going through his head, this is what's going through her head. It's the fact we're able to take it in so effortlessly that allows us to understand the scene. Yeah, so we're able to, and I remember watching this movie as a as a child who of course hadn't had the benefit of studying how theory of mine works in the brains of children and adults, and I still found it very funny. I knew exactly what was happening, who was misunderstanding, who knew
阻止他的妻子与其他男人约会。我们也明白她对发生的事情一无所得。但对我来说有趣的是，莉安，我们毫不费力地领会了这一切。当人们看电影时，没有人会坐下来对自己说，好吧，这就是这个人脑子里想的，这就是那个人脑子里想的。正是因为我们能够如此毫不费力地领会这一切，我们才能理解这个场景。是的，所以我们能够，我记得我小时候看这部电影时，当然还没有研究过心理理论如何在儿童和成人的大脑中运作的好处，我仍然觉得它非常有趣。我确切地知道发生了什么，谁误解了谁，谁知道
what other people didn't know, and so on in order to be able to enjoy the scene and really the entire movie. So you used the term just now, Theory of Mind. It's a term that you and other researchers have to describe our capacity to understand what is happening in the minds of other people. Can you explain what that term means to me? Yes. So I should say that many psychologists and neuroscientists
其他人不知道的事，等等，以便能够欣赏这个场景，甚至整部电影。所以你刚才用到了这个词，“心智理论”（Theory of Mind）。这是你和其他研究人员用来描述我们理解他人内心发生的事情的能力的一个词。你能向我解释一下这个词的意思吗？好的。所以我要说的是，许多心理学家和神经科学家
use a number of different terms. Theory of mind is one of those terms and that describes the theory that we all have, ordinary people have, about other people's minds. And what I mean by that is how we understand that other people have thoughts, beliefs, desires, and intentions, mental states in general. And so other terms that have been used
使用了许多不同的术语。心智理论就是其中之一，它描述了我们所有人、普通人对他人内心世界的理论。我的意思是，我们如何理解其他人有思想、信念、欲望和意图，也就是一般的精神状态。所以其他曾被用于
for this general cognitive capacity include mental state reasoning, mentalizing, reasoning about intentions, and so on. And again, the fact that we do it so effortlessly, many of us don't even realize that we are doing it. Many of us don't realize that if we are having a conversation and we were not able to intuit what was happening in someone else's mind, really difficult to have a conversation.
这种一般认知能力的术语包括心智状态推理、心智化、对意图的推理等等。再说一次，我们毫不费力地做到这一点的这一事实，让我们许多人甚至没有意识到我们在这样做。我们中的许多人没有意识到，如果我们正在进行对话，而我们无法直觉到别人心里在想什么，那么进行对话将是非常困难的。
Exactly. Even as you and I are having this conversation, Shankar, I'm trying to figure out, you know, what it is that you want to know and how to explain the term theory of mine in a way that will be accessible and so on. And sometimes we take different cues from people as we're having that conversation, whether they're nodding their heads, whether they're pausing, whether they look confused and so on. And so we take in all of that information to figure out what people are thinking and how
没错。即使你和我正在进行这场对话，尚卡尔，我也在试图弄清楚，你知道的，你想知道什么，以及如何以一种通俗易懂的方式来解释“心智理论”这个词，等等。有时，在我们进行对话时，我们会从人们那里捕捉到不同的线索，无论是他们是否在点头，是否在停顿，看起来是否困惑，等等。因此，我们吸收所有这些信息来弄清楚人们在想什么以及
they're responding to the information that we're giving them. Nearly all the world's greatest stories ask you to exercise theory of mind, to inhabit the minds of other people. Think of books such as Kazoo or Ishigoro's The Remains of the Day, or TV shows such as Breaking Bad, or musicals like Hamilton. I think it's really important that we're able to take the perspective of different characters when we're watching movies, watching TV shows, reading books, and often as the reader, as the viewer, we have a sort of different, in some cases, omniscient perspective. We can see the scene unfolding in a way that characters within the scene cannot. And so on one level, we understand what's going on
他们对我们提供的信息作何反应。世界上几乎所有最伟大的故事都要求你运用心智理论，去揣摩其他人的内心世界。想想卡齐欧·石黑uro的《长日将尽》这样的书，或者《绝命毒师》这样的电视剧，或者《汉密尔顿》这样的音乐剧。我认为非常重要的是，当我们看电影、看电视剧、读书时，我们能够采取不同角色的视角，而且通常作为读者、作为观众，我们有一种不同寻常的、在某些情况下是全知全能的视角。我们可以看到场景的展开，而场景中的角色却无法看到。因此，在某种程度上，我们理解了正在发生的事情，
in a way that characters within the story do not. And we also are able to not just get into the minds of characters but get into the hearts of characters as well. So we know how they're feeling and how they're reacting and responding in ways that maybe other characters in the story don't. So psychologists have found different ways to measure this ability and to test how it develops in small children. What are they finally at? Is this a skill we are born with at birth or is it something that develops over time?
而这是故事中的角色所没有的。我们不仅能够进入角色的头脑，还能够进入角色的心灵。因此，我们可以通过故事中其他角色可能没有的方式了解他们的感受以及他们的反应和回应。因此，心理学家已经找到了各种方法来衡量这种能力，并测试它如何在幼儿身上发展。他们的最终结论是什么？这是一项我们生来就有的技能，还是随着时间推移而发展的技能？
Is this a skill we are born with at birth? Or is it something that develops over time? This is a little bit controversial in the field, but I think what is generally recognized in the field is that at least children's capacity for explicit theory of mind being able to reason and verbalize answers to theory of mind tasks, that ability emerges between the ages of three and five years.
这是一项我们生来就有的技能吗？还是随着时间推移而发展的技能？这在学术界有点争议，但我认为学术界普遍认同的是，至少儿童对显性心智理论的能力——即能够对心智理论任务进行推理并用语言表达答案——这种能力出现在三到五岁之间。
Psychologists are able to administer batteries of theory of mind task to young children to figure out when exactly it is that individual children are able to think about other agents in the world as having minds that are maybe separate from the reality of a situation. Some of these tests create artificial situations where one character knows more than another. Daniel, in Mrs. Doubtfire, understands the sub-diffuse she is perpetrating. Miranda does not. The tests evaluate where the children can keep track of all the different perspectives in the minds of different characters,
心理学家能够对幼儿实施一系列心智理论任务，以弄清楚单个儿童到底在什么时候能够将世界上其他主体视为拥有可能独立于情境现实的心智。其中一些测试创造了人工情境，其中一个角色的了解多于另一个角色。在《窈窕奶爸》中，丹尼尔理解他正在策划的易容。米兰达则不然。这些测试评估儿童是否能够追踪不同角色心中的所有不同观点，
that one person has a belief that's true, for example, and another has a belief that's false. So one example of a false belief task would be the Sally and task, in which you have two puppets, Sally and Anne. Sally is playing with a ball and then she takes the ball and puts it away in a basket. She leaves the room and another puppet comes in and moves the ball to a different location and then children are asked when Sally comes back into the room, where does she think her ball is? Did Sally see Anne move the block? Because she was outside.
比如一个人有真实的信念，而另一个人有虚假的信念。因此，错误信念任务的一个例子是萨莉和安妮任务，其中你有两个木偶，萨莉和安妮。萨莉正在玩一个球，然后她把球拿走并放进一个篮子里。她离开了房间，另一个木偶进来把球移到了另一个地方，然后当萨莉回到房间时，孩子们被问到：她认为她的球在哪里？萨莉看到安妮移动积木了吗？因为她在外面。
That's right. So, that's right. She didn't see. So, when Sally come back in, what where will she think the block is? And there, but it's not it's in there. So, she'll think it's in there. And three-year-old children will tend to say that she thinks the ball is where it really is,
没错。所以，没错。她没看到。因此，当萨莉回来时，她会认为积木在哪里？在那里，但它不在那儿，它在那里。所以，她会认为它在那里。三岁的孩子往往会说她认为球在它真正所在的地方，
even though she's not supposed to know that, Anne came in and moved her ball whereas older children by the time children are five, they know that Sally has a false belief about where that ball is. Right. So once Anne moves the ball, a small children deduce or believe that Sally must somehow intuitively also know that the ball has been moved to the new location, whereas older children realize, no, Sally, in fact, does not have the same mind as Anne, and what Anne knows is not what Sally knows.
即使她不应该知道安妮进来并移走了她的球，而较大的孩子，到五岁的时候，就知道萨莉对球在哪里有一个错误的信念。没错。所以一旦安妮移走了球，小孩子就会推断或相信萨莉某种程度上一定也直觉到了球已经被移到了新的位置，而较大的孩子则意识到，不，事实上萨莉的心智和安妮不一样，安妮知道的并不就是萨莉知道的。
Sally knows only what she knows, and as far as she knows, the ball is in the old location. So when she returns to the room, she's gonna guess that that's where it's still is. Why do you think she'll think that? I don't know, to keep put it there. Yes, that's exactly right. So younger children through old children
萨莉只知道她所知道的，就她所知，球还在原来的位置。所以当她回到房间时，她会猜那依然是它所在的地方。你为什么认为她会这么想？我不知道，把它放在那里的。是的，完全正确。所以年龄较小的孩子到年长的孩子
don't have a concept that people could have beliefs in their heads that depart from the reality of the world, the facts of the situation. So we've looked at a couple of humorous examples of how theory of mind operates. But I want to stress again, this capacity we have to intuit what's happening in the minds of other people. This is a skill that we use all the time. Can you talk a moment, Leigh Ann, about what would happen if we lack this skill? Are there people in fact who do not have this skill
没有这样的概念，即人们脑海中的信念可能会背离世界的现实、情况的事实。因此，我们看了一些幽默的例子，了解心智理论是如何运作的。但我想再次强调，我们直觉感知他人内心活动的能力。这是我们一直在使用的一项技能。莉安，你能谈谈如果我们缺乏这项技能会发生什么吗？生活中确实有人不具备这项技能吗？
as they move through life? Yeah, this is in a uniform capacity that we see the same in all people across all situations. It can be dependent on the individual. It can be dependent on the context, even in healthy, typical populations. We've also looked at specific patient populations as well, including patients with specific brain damage. We've looked at prison inmates with a clinical diagnosis
随着生活的推进？是的，这不是我们在所有人、所有情况下都能看到的千篇一律的能力。它可能取决于个人。它甚至可以取决于背景，即使在健康、典型的群体中也是如此。我们还研究了特定的患者群体，包括患有特定脑损伤的患者。我们研究了具有临床诊断的监狱犯人
of psychopathy, and we've looked at high functioning adults with autism. And so we've seen sort of a range of behavioral patterns across different populations of people in terms of how they use and how they deploy theory of mind capacities for moral judgments in particular. Leon and others have found that people who have a difficult time inturing what is going on in the minds of other people find themselves hamstrung as they go through life. They can be awkward in interpersonal settings.
患有精神病态，我们研究了患有自闭症的高功能成年人。因此，我们在不同人群中看到了各种行为模式，特别是在他们如何使用和部署心智理论能力来进行道德判断方面。莉安和其他人发现，那些难以直觉感知他人内心活动的人在生活中会发现自己受到掣肘。他们在人际交往环境中可能会显得尴尬。
They can fail to read the room in a meeting. They may even demonstrate reduced empathy for others. Moving through the world, without an understanding that other minds are different than your own, that they have different intentions, desires, and hopes, this is like playing music without a sense of rhythm. You find yourself constantly out of sync with your fellow musicians. I mean, we've all been a situation where a joke falls flat because the person who's telling the joke
他们可能无法在会议中看清形势。他们甚至可能对他人表现出较低的同理心。在世界上前行，如果不理解其他的心智不同于你自己的心智，它们有着不同的意图、欲望和希望，这就像是在没有节奏感的情况下弹奏音乐。你会发现自己与周围的音乐家总是合不上拍。我的意思是，我们都遇到过这样的情况：一个笑话冷场了，因为讲笑话的人
is unable to appropriately assess the mood in this space or what other people know or don't know and so on. Right. And so certainly there are many cases of that. And then there are sort of the opposite cases where we really admire individuals for having a keen sense of what other people are thinking and feeling, and able to shape a conversation or discussion in that way. You know, I'm reminded of the work of the psychologist, E. Tori Higgins, who's done some work looking
无法适当地评估这个空间里的情绪，或者其他人知道或不知道什么，等等。对。所以这方面的例子肯定有很多。然后还有那种相反的情况，我们非常钦佩那些对别人的想法和感受有敏锐洞察力、并能以此塑造对话或讨论的个人。你知道，我想起了心理学家E·托里·希金斯（E. Tory Higgins）的工作，他做了一些研究
at politicians who are very skilled at reading a room. He has described this phenomenon called audience, where in some ways the politicians are changing what they say in order to be best received by the people in the room. They're in some ways manipulating the people in the room, but they're also being manipulated by the people in the room so that what they say aligns with the audience in the room. It's interesting. So theory of mind is not just, I suppose, on an interpersonal level, it can also happen at a group setting where we entue how a group of people is feeling or feeling
那些非常善于察言观色的政客。他描述了一种叫做“受众”的现象，在某些情况下，政客们改变他们所说的话，以便被房间里的人最好地接受。他们在某种程度上操纵了房间里的人，但他们也被房间里的人所操纵，以至于他们所说的话与房间里的听众保持一致。这很有趣。所以心智理论不仅，我想，在人际交往层面上，它也可以发生在群体环境中，我们直觉感知一群人的感觉或感受
toward us. Yeah, you're right. And so it can be very complicated trying to figure out how theory of mind plays out in any given situation. You know, on my lab, when I'm particularly in on Zoom in the pandemic, it can be a lot harder to read the room if you will figure out, you know, on my lab, when I'm particularly in Zoom in the pandemic, it can be a lot harder to read the room if you will figure out, you know, as a group how people are doing and how to shape that space. Leon and other researchers have tried to understand how the physical brain produces the superpower. Surprisingly, they found a specific region of the brain plays a crucial role.
对我们的态度。是的，你是对的。因此，试图弄清楚心智理论在任何给定情况下是如何发挥作用的，可能会非常复杂。你知道，在我的实验室里，尤其是在大流行期间使用Zoom时，如果你愿意的话，很难看清房间里的情况，弄清楚，你知道的，在我的实验室里，当我特别在Zoom上处于大流行期间时，如果你愿意的话，很难看清房间里的情况，弄清楚，你知道的，作为一个群体，大家的状况如何以及如何塑造那个空间。莉安和其他研究人员试图了解物理大脑是如何产生这种超能力的。令人惊讶的是，他们发现大脑的一个特定区域起着至关重要的作用。
They've even found you can temporarily disrupt this brain region and profoundly change the ways people think and act. That's when we come back. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. To navigate our social worlds, we rely on something psychologists call theory of mind. It's our ability to guess the intentions, desires, and motivations of other people. When your coworker tells you she's thrilled it's Monday, you know that sarcasm because you unconsciously pick up the intention behind her words. But it's amazing as our social antenna can be.
他们甚至发现，你可以暂时扰乱这个大脑区域，并深刻改变人们的思考和行动方式。广告回来后继续。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。为了在我们的社交世界中航行，我们依赖于心理学家称之为心智理论的东西。这是我们猜测他人意图、欲望和动机的能力。当你的同事告诉你她很高兴今天是星期一时，你知道那是讽刺，因为你无意识地捕捉到了她话语背后的意图。但尽管我们的社交天线有时很神奇，
They can also sometimes make mistakes. We can misread other people's intentions. Maybe your coworker really does like Mondays. Psychologist and neuroscientist Leanne Young studies how our brains read intention, both the intentions of others and of ourselves, especially when it comes to our moral judgments. Leanne, you run experiments where you test how volunteers react to a story about a woman who accidentally poisoned her friend. Can you tell me the setup of the experiment and describe the scenario in more detail?
它们有时也会犯错。我们可能会误读别人的意图。也许你的同事真的很喜欢星期一。心理学家兼神经科学家莉安·杨研究我们的大脑如何解读意图，包括他人的意图和我们自己的意图，特别是在涉及我们的道德判断时。莉安，你做过一些实验，测试志愿者对一个关于无意中毒害朋友的女性的故事的反应。你能告诉我实验的设置并更详细地描述这个场景吗？
Yes, absolutely. So we usually have our subjects read stories that we write about other people who are performing actions that have effects on other people in the scenario. So in one story, we have a person named Grace who put some powder into a co-workers coffee. And in one scenario, she thinks the powder is sugar, but the powder turns out to be poison. And she ends up poisoning her friend. So that's a version of the scenario in which someone causes harm to someone else by accident because of a false belief.
好的，没问题。因此，我们通常会让受试者阅读我们编写的故事，关于其他人正在做出对场景中的其他人产生影响的行为。所以在其中一个故事中，我们有一个名叫格蕾丝的人，她把一些粉末放进同事的咖啡里。在一个场景中，她以为这种粉末是糖，但粉末结果却是毒药。她最终毒害了她的朋友。所以这是场景的一个版本，其中有人由于错误的信念而意外伤害了其他人。
In another version of the story, Grace puts powder into her co-workers' coffee, she thinks the powder is poison, but it turns out to be sugar. So that's a situation in which she has a harmful intention, but no harm is done. So in these two cases, there is a conflict between the intention of the agent and the outcome of the agent's action. And so we can ask our volunteer participants for their moral judgments of both the person, the agent performing the action, and also the action itself, whether this action is morally permissible or morally forbidden. And using these kinds of scenarios and these kinds of
在故事的另一个版本中，格蕾丝把粉末放进同事的咖啡里，她以为粉末是毒药，但结果却是糖。所以这是一种情况，她有伤害的意图，但没有造成伤害。因此，在这两种情况下，行动者的意图和行动者的行动结果之间存在冲突。因此，我们可以询问我们的志愿者参与者，他们对执行该动作的人（即行动者）本身以及动作本身（该动作在道德上是允许的还是在道德上是禁止的）的道德判断。通过使用这些场景和这些类型的
moral judgment skills, we can get a sense for the extent to which different people rely on information about intentions to make their moral judgments. So you and I, for instance, could have very different views about how bad it is to accidentally poison a coworker. And sort of depending on the circumstances, there could be a situation in which there's just no way she could have known maybe somebody swapped the sugar and the poison, and she had the best of intentions. And so those are cases where there's a lot of flexibility for individual variation in
道德判断技能，我们可以了解不同人群在多大程度上依赖关于意图的信息来做出他们的道德判断。例如，你和我可能对意外毒害同事的严重程度有非常不同的看法。根据具体情况的不同，可能会出现这样一种情况：她绝对不可能知道，也许有人把糖和毒药调换了，而她怀揣着最好的意图。因此，在这些情况下，个人差异有很大的灵活性
moral judgments. We can apply that same reasoning to the case of a failed attempt to cause harm to. Some people might focus more on the neutral outcome, the fact that nothing bad happened at all, whereas other folks might focus a lot more on the fact that this person just tried to poison their coworker, and that's very, very bad. Yeah, as I was listening to those scenarios, I would have said that the person who didn't mean to harm her friend but accidentally caused harm is in fact innocent, but the person who didn't cause harm when she intended to cause harm was in fact culpable that this was an act of attempted murder.
道德判断。我们可以将同样的推理应用到未能造成伤害的企图的情况中。有些人可能更关注中性的结果，即没有发生任何坏事的事实，而另其他人可能更关注这个人只是试图毒害他们的同事，而这是非常非常坏的事实。是的，当我听那些场景时，我会说那个无意伤害她的朋友却意外造成伤害的人实际上是无辜的，但是那个意图造成伤害却没有造成伤害的人实际上是有罪的，这是一个谋杀未遂的行为。
You have the insight to study not just how people reach different conclusions, but how their brains were operating as they reached these different moral judgments. Can you tell me about those studies and what you found, Leon? So we've run a number of studies now using brain imaging techniques to look at how people's brains are responding as they're making moral judgments of these kinds of cases. And so what we found in one study was that a brain region called the right temporal pyridol junction, which is right above and behind your right ear, processes information about people's intentions. And what we found was that the more in individuals, uh, right temporal
你不仅有洞察力去研究人们如何得出不同的结论，还能研究当他们得出这些不同的道德判断时，他们的大脑是如何运作的。莉安，你能告诉我那些研究以及你发现了什么吗？所以我们现在已经使用脑成像技术进行了多项研究，以观察人们在对这些情况做出道德判断时大脑是如何反应的。我们在其中一项研究中发现，大脑中一个名为右颞顶交界处的区域（就在你右耳上方和后方），负责处理关于人们意图的信息。我们发现，个体的这个“右颞顶
pyridol junction responds, as they are making these moral judgments, the more they are using information about innocent intentions to let the person who caused harm by accident off the hook. And so we see this correlation between brain activity and this region that tracks intention information and the moral judgments that people are making of accidental harms.
交界处”在他们做出这些道德判断时的反应越强烈，他们在让因意外造成伤害的人免责时，就会更多地利用关于无辜意图的信息。因此，我们看到大脑活动与这个追踪意图信息的区域之间存在这种相关性，以及人们对意外伤害所做出的道德判断。
So you could of course say that merely because a brain region appears active, you don't necessarily know that it's actually connected to the outcome and behavior that you're seeing, but you've got to step further to actually test whether this brain region is in fact implicated in understanding the intentions of others. Tell me how you've done this Leon. In addition to using brain imaging,
所以你当然可以说，仅仅因为一个大脑区域看起来很活跃，你并不一定知道它实际上与你看到的结局和行为有关，但你又向前迈进了一步，实际测试这个大脑区域是否真的与理解他人意图有关。莉安，告诉我是怎么做到的。除了使用脑成像，
which helps us to track what brains are doing as people are making moral judgments, we've also used a technique called Trainscranial Magnetic Stimulation, or TMS, for short, to temporarily disrupt activity in this particular brain region, the right temporal-pridal junction, to see what effect that has on the moral
这有助于我们追踪人们在做出道德判断时大脑在做什么，我们还使用了一种名为经颅磁刺激（简称TMS）的技术，来暂时扰乱特定大脑区域（右颞顶交界处）的活动，以观察它对人类道德判断产生的影响
judgments that people make. And so when we temporarily disrupt activity in this brain region, we see that people's moral judgments rely less on information about intentions in these kinds of cases that we've been talking about. So to give you an example, if you are reading a story about somebody who tries to poison their friend, but fails to do so because they mistook the substance for poison, but it was in fact sugar, if I am disrupting activity
人们做出的判断。因此，当我们暂时扰乱该大脑区域的活动时，我们发现人们的道德判断在前面我们一直在讨论的这类情况下，较少依赖关于意图的信息。举个例子，如果你正在读一个关于某人试图毒害他们的朋友但由于误把物质当成毒药而未能成功，但它实际上是糖的故事，如果我扰乱了活动
in your right-temperprile junction, you'll be more likely to say that that is more okay than if I didn't disrupt activity in your right temporal-pridal junction. That is actually somewhat disturbing, isn't it? The idea that you disrupt a small portion of my brain and something that I think of as core to myself, how I think of myself as being a moral person can be altered by small changes in neurochemistry. I think a lot of us share the intuition that is confirmed
在你右颞顶交界处，你更有可能说这比我没有扰乱你右颞顶交界处的活动更能让人接受。这实际上有点令人不安，不是吗？这种想法是，你扰乱了我大脑的一小部分，而我认为这对我至关重要，我认为自己是一个有道德的人，却可以通过神经化学的小改变而改变。我想我们很多人都有这种直觉，并且得到了证实
by recent empirical work in psychology that how we think about moral situations or moral beliefs are really central to what we consider to be our identity. We take our moral identity central to our self-concept. And so to think that interventions, scientific interventions, can alter our moral judgments is in some ways upsetting. That said, as neuroscientists, we've assumed all along that our moral judgments have some place in the brain. And so it stands to reason that when you disrupt activity in people's brains that you will be disrupting
通过心理学最近的实证研究，我们如何思考道德情境或道德信念，确实是我们认为是我们的身份的核心。我们将我们的道德身份视为自我概念的核心。因此，认为干预措施、科学干预措施可以改变我们的道德判断，在某些情况下是令人不安的。话虽如此，作为神经科学家，我们一直认为我们的道德判断在大脑中有其位置。因此，顺理成章的是，当你扰乱人类大脑中的活动时，你也将扰乱
the kinds of judgments that we'll be disrupting the kinds of judgments that we'll be making too, including moral judgments. And there is so much work on the unconscious influences on behavior. And so, social psychologists have shown that the smell of freshly baked cookies can alter charitable giving behavior,
我们将做出的判断的种类，也将扰乱我们将要做出的判断，包括道德判断。而且有那么多关于对行为无意识影响的研究。因此，社会心理学家已经表明，刚出炉的曲奇饼干的香味可以改变慈善捐赠行为，
whether someone is in a rush to get somewhere, can change or impact the likelihood of they're stopping to give money to a homeless person. I think that there are environmental influences, there are cultural differences in the degree to which people rely on intention information. And so in many ways, I'm not sure that I would be more upset by the fact that smelling fresh cookies is going to impact my behavior or somebody applying transcranial magnetic stimulation to my brain is going to impact my behavior or my decision-making.
一个人是否赶时间去某地，可以改变或影响他们停下来给无家可归的人钱的可能性。我认为存在环境影响，并且在人们对意图信息的依赖程度上存在文化差异。所以在很多方面，我不确定我是否会因为闻到新鲜曲奇饼干会影响我的行为，或者有人对我的大脑应用经颅磁刺激会影响我的行为或决策而感到更加不安。
So much of our moral reasoning depends on our ability to consider the intentions of other people. When someone makes a mistake but we see they didn't mean to do it, we usually are less harsh with them. This is why kids say it was an accident. But as Leon points out, a number of factors can change how and whether we are willing to consider the intentions of a wrong door. When someone steps on your toe in the hallway, you automatically assume they didn't mean to do it. Your mind gravitates to an innocent explanation.
我们的许多道德推理都取决于我们考虑他人意图的能力。当某人犯了错误但我们看到他不是故意的时，我们通常对他们没那么严厉。这就是为什么孩子们说“这不是故意的”原因。但正如莉安指出的那样，许多因素可以改变我们是否愿意以及如何愿意考虑做错事者的意图。当某人在走廊里踩到你的脚时，你自动假定他不是故意的。你的大脑倾向于一个无辜的解释。
But other situations work the opposite way. They make it nearly impossible for us to think about the intentions behind an outcome. Consider this disturbing new story out of Chicago. At 6 o'clock in off-duty Chicago police officer now sided with hitting and killing a nine-year-old boy riding his bike in West Rogers Park. Hershel Weinberger died Wednesday night after a pickup truck hit him in the crosswalk at Sacramento in Chase right by his house. The driver who stayed at the scene was that off-duty police officer. He's been sighted with him.
但其他情况则正好相反。它们让我们几乎不可能去思考结果背后的意图。考虑一下芝加哥发生的一则令人不安的新闻。下午6点，一名下班的芝加哥警察被指控在西罗杰斯公园撞倒并撞死了一名骑自行车的九岁男孩。赫舍尔·温伯格在周三晚上在萨克拉门托和蔡斯交叉路口的斑马线上被一辆皮卡撞倒后身亡，地点就在他家附近。留在现场的司机正是那名下班的警察。他已被传讯。
Now, when I hear this, I find it really difficult to think about whether the police officer meant to do any harm. A nine-year-old child is dead. The intentions of the driver seem irrelevant. And when I hear, as actually happened in this case, that the police officer was given a traffic citation rather than a criminal charge, I feel outraged. But here's the thing, if the cop had run a stop sign
现在，当我听到这个消息时，我发现很难去思考这个警察是否本意是要造成任何伤害。一个九岁的小孩死了。司机的意图似乎无关紧要。当我听到，正如这个案件中实际发生的那样，警察受到的是交通违章传讯而不是刑事指控时，我感到愤怒。但问题是，如果这个警察闯了红灯
and that was the end of it, do I think he should be criminally charged? That would be absurd. So the same actions, with the same intentions, caused my mind to reach for very different conclusions. There is this terrible tension between the fact that nobody meant any harm, nobody meant to kill anyone, and the fact that this nine year old boy died. And to take it a step further, you could think of a case in which he hadn't
事情就这么结束了，我认为他应该受到刑事指控吗？那太荒谬了。因此，同样的行动，带着同样的意图，让我的大脑得出了截然不同的结论。这其中存在着一种可怕的张力：一方面没有人意图造成伤害，没有人意图杀死任何人，而另一方面这个九岁小男孩死了。再深入一步，你可以想象这样一个案子：他甚至没有
run a stop sign. Maybe he was just driving and the child came out of nowhere. I think we would still have the intuition that if you caused that event to happen, if you caused that bad outcome, then there is a way in which you are causally responsible for something very bad that you didn't know that you would be doing and maybe could not have prevented. And so it's really tricky to figure out how to handle that kind of case, as you point out, I think different people have different responses to what happened and what should be done and how to prevent that from happening again. There are other situations where our ability to think about intentions gets disabled.
闯红灯。也许他只是在开车，而孩子突然从某个地方冲了出来。我想我们仍然会有这样一种直觉：如果你导致了那个事件的发生，如果你造成了那个不好的结果，那么在某种程度上，你对一件你不知道自己会做、也许无法阻止的非常糟糕的事情负有因果责任。因此，弄清楚如何处理那种情况真的很棘手，正如你所指出的，我认为不同的人对发生的事情、应该做的事情以及如何防止类似事件再次发生有着不同的反应。还有其他一些情况，我们思考意图的能力会失效。
If we hear that someone has knowingly committed incest with a sibling, you might not stop to think about whether both siblings consented or that no one else was affected. The violation of the taboo, the outcome, is all that matters. And often in these cases, we downplay intent information. It doesn't matter that you didn't know the fact that you did it is bad enough. And so that happens for, again,
如果我们听说某人知情与亲兄弟姐妹乱伦，你可能不会停下来思考两个兄弟姐妹是否都同意或者是否没有其他人受到影响。违背禁忌，即结果，才是最重要的。通常在这些情况下，我们会淡化意图信息。你不知道这并不重要，你做了这件事这个事实本身就已经够糟糕的了。因此，这种情况再次发生的原因是
as I mentioned, violations related to food and sex and those are cases in which once you are sort of defiled, there's very little that you can do to get clean again. And there's very little that you could say to sort of justify or mitigate the behavior, including that you didn't know or that it wasn't done on purpose. I want to talk a moment, Leanne, about how our understanding of events changes as our understanding of the intentions behind those events changes.
正如我所提到的，与食物和性相关的违规行为，在这些情况下，一旦你被玷污了，你几乎无能为力来恢复纯洁。而且你几乎说不出什么来为这种行为辩解或减轻罪责，包括你不知道或者这不是故意的。莉安，我想花点时间谈谈，随着我们对这些事件背后的意图的理解发生变化，我们对事件的理解是如何变化的。
On September 11, 2001, when the first plane hit the World Trade Center tower, no one knew what was happening. Many new reports, in fact, speculated it might have been some kind of accident. But when the second plane hit, it changed the way people understood what was happening. The second plane made it clear the attacks were intentional. I want to play you a clip of a bystander talking to CBS News, at the point where this clip starts, only the first plane has hit the towers. We heard it and because I was just like standing there, pretty much looking out the window,
2001年9月11日，当第一架飞机撞击世界贸易中心双子塔时，没有人知道发生了什么。事实上，许多新闻报道推测这可能某种事故。但当第二架飞机撞击时，它改变了人们对正在发生的事情的理解。第二架飞机清楚地表明这些袭击是有意为之的。我想放一段旁观者与CBS新闻对话的剪辑，当这段剪辑开始时，只有第一架飞机撞击了双子塔。我们听到了它，因为我当时只是站在那里，差不多是向窗外看，
I didn't see what caused it or if there was an impact. So you have no idea right now? Out of another one, another plane just hit. Right, oh my god, another plane has just hit another building. Pull right into the middle of it, explosion. Like, oh, it's right in the middle of the building. This one into the east tower. Yes, that was definitely look like it was on purpose.
我没有看到是什么引起了它，或者是否发生了撞击。所以你现在完全不知道？又来了一架，又有一架飞机撞上去了！没错，天哪，另一架飞机刚刚撞上了另一栋大楼。直接撞进了正中间，发生了爆炸。就像，哦，它就在大楼的正中间。这架撞入了东塔。是的，那看起来绝对是故意的。
You saw a plane. Yeah, I just saw a plane go in to the building. So as soon as the second plane hits Leanne, this bystanders understanding of the intentions behind the event changes, and that changes her understanding of the event itself. Yeah, exactly. So whether we interpret an event as just a natural disaster or a technical malfunction or as a coordinated planned attack can really affect the way that we respond to those events. And so when we hear about something like that, I think, first we ask ourselves or read the news to find out what happened, and then we
你看到一架飞机了。是的，我刚看到一架飞机撞进了大楼。因此，莉安，一旦第二架飞机撞击，这位旁观者对事件背后意图的理解就改变了，这改变了她对事件本身的理解。是的，完全正确。因此，我们是将一个事件解释为仅仅是一场自然灾害、技术故障，还是一次协同策划的袭击，这确实会影响我们对这些事件的反应。因此，当我们听到这样的事情时，我认为，首先我们会问自己或阅读新闻以找出发生了什么，然后我们
want to know why and who if relevant. So we ask those kinds of questions in that order. And as you say, our answers to those questions really help shape our understanding of an event as either misfortune or we are trying to figure out who did it and why and what we can do to prevent it from happening in the future. So do you think this is why in some ways we have this capacity in our heads in the first place? I remember on 9-11 I was working in the newsroom of the Washington Post and once we knew that two planes had hit the World Trade Center and a third plane had hit the Pentagon, it was clear that we were under attack, at which point it prompted us to say, okay, what should we do? Could we be under attack?
想知道为什么以及谁（如果相关的话）。所以我们按这个顺序问这些类型的问题。正如你所说，我们对这些问题的回答确实有助于将一个事件理解为不幸，或者我们在试图弄清楚是谁干的、为什么以及我们可以做些什么来防止它在未来再次发生。所以你认为这就是为什么在某种程度上我们脑子里首先具备这种能力的原因吗？我记得在9-11那天，我在《华盛顿邮报》的新闻编辑室工作，一旦我们知道两架飞机撞击了世界贸易中心，第三架飞机撞击了五角大楼，很显然我们遭到了袭击，当时这促使我们说，好吧，我们该怎么办？我们可能会遭到袭击吗？
Is there some danger that's facing us? And of course, if our reading of the events had been different, if we had said, all right, this was an isolated accident. It was just a plane that basically lost control and happened to fly into the World Trade Center building. Our response to the incident would be entirely different. We would say, okay, we need to have better flight security measures, better pilot training. So our responses to the events are very different as we read the intentions behind those events.
我们是否面临着某种危险？当然，如果我们对事件的解读不同，如果我们说，好吧，这是一起孤立的事故。这只是一架基本上失控并碰巧飞入世界贸易中心大楼的飞机。我们对这一事件的反应将完全不同。我们会说，好吧，我们需要有更好的航班安全措施，更好的飞行员培训。因此，当我们解读这些事件背后的意图时，我们对事件的反应是非常不同的。
And I'm wondering, do you think this might be partly why our brains come with this capacity to read intentions because as we read intentions, it tells us how to respond to the world. Absolutely. I think our ability to read intentions tells us how to evaluate the events around us, how to understand them, how to predict what's going to happen in the future
我想知道，你认为这是否部分解释了为什么我们的大脑生来就具备这种解读意图的能力，因为当我们解读意图时，它告诉我们如何对世界做出反应？绝对是的。我认为我们解读意图的能力告诉我们如何评估我们周围的事件，如何理解它们，如何预测未来将要发生的事情
and how to interact with people in the present. And so all of that depends on our ability to figure out intentions and distinguished intentional events from accidental events. This happens in a lot of news events that we read. When we read about a building collapsing, we think, you know, what happened and how can we prevent that from happening in the future? And again, our answers to those questions depend on whether that happened on purpose, whether someone caused it or whether it was an earthquake, for instance. And so I think your question about
以及如何在当下与人交往。因此，所有这一切都取决于我们弄清意图并将有意事件与意外事件区分开来的能力。我们在阅读的许多新闻事件中都看到了这一点。当我们读到一栋大楼倒塌时，我们会想，你知道，发生了什么，我们如何防止未来再次发生这种情况？同样，我们对这些问题的回答取决于这是否是故意的，是否有人造成的，或者例如这是否是一场地震。所以我想你关于
why it is that we have this capacity is a really important one. And I think we don't have an answer to that question yet as a psychologist, in part because there's so many reasons why that capacity for a theory of mind could be important. We need to think about other people's minds in order to figure out whom to learn from, who's the right expert in a particular domain. We need to know about people's intentions to figure out who our friends are,
我们为什么拥有这种能力是一个非常重要的问题。作为心理学家，我认为我们目前还没有找到这个问题的答案，部分原因在于，心智解读能力的至关重要性有着太多的原因。我们需要揣摩他人的心思，以便弄清楚应该向谁学习，谁才是某个特定领域的真正专家。我们需要了解别人的意图，从而分辨出谁是我们的朋友，
who to avoid, whom to punish, whether to punish, and we need to read people's intentions in any ordinary interaction, like having a conversation and figuring out what to say and how to respond. When we come back, the ability we have to read other people's minds can be a super power, but this super power can fail us, sometimes with terrible consequences. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Our ability to read the minds of other people is something of a mental superpower. It allows us to effortlessly navigate a complex social world
谁应该回避，谁应该惩罚，是否应该惩罚，并且我们需要在任何日常互动中解读人们的意图，比如进行对话并弄清楚该说些什么以及如何回应。稍后回来，我们解读他人心智的能力可以是一种超能力，但这种超能力可能会让我们失望，有时甚至会带来可怕的后果。您正在收听的是《隐藏的心智》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的心智》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们解读他人心智的能力算是一种心理上的超能力。它使我们能够毫不费力地在复杂的社会世界中穿行，
and entue what other people want and how they feel. This superpower helps us understand when bad things happen by accident, when they happen by design, and it allows us to tell friend from foe. Of course, the fact that our minds read so much into the intentions of others also makes the superpower ripe for exploitation by con artist, marketing gurus and politicians. At Boston College, neuroscientists Leanne Young studies the psychology of theory of mind our ability to think about the mental states of others including their intentions. In her lab, she and her colleagues explore the role of intention when it comes to making moral judgments. Leanne, I want to talk about
并推断出别人的愿望和感受。这种超能力有助于我们理解什么时候坏事是偶然发生的，什么时候是蓄意为之，它还能让我们分清敌友。当然，我们的心智对他人意图的过度解读，也使得这种超能力极易被骗子、营销大师和政客利用。在波士顿学院，神经科学家莉安·杨研究的是心智解读的心理学，也就是我们思考他人心理状态（包括他们的意图）的能力。在她的实验室里，她和同事们探讨了在做出道德判断时意图所起的作用。莉安，我想谈谈
some ways in which our ability to read other people's intentions can sometimes go wrong. And I want to start again with television and the arts. There's a very funny scene in the TV show Seinfeld. The character George has just gone on a date with a new love interest. They drive back to her and the arts, there's a very funny scene in the TV show Seinfeld. The character George has just gone on a date with a new love interest. They drive back to her apartment, they're sitting in the car outside its midnight, the air is crackling with sexual tension, and here's what happens next. So thanks for dinner, it was great. Okay.
我们解读他人意图的能力有时会出错的一些方式。我想再次从电视和艺术说起。电视剧《宋飞正传》里有一个非常搞笑的场景。角色乔治刚刚和一位新的心仪对象约会归来。他们开车回她……和艺术，电视剧《宋飞正传》里有一个非常搞笑的场景。角色乔治刚刚和一位新的心仪对象约会归来。他们开车回到她的公寓，半夜坐在车外的车里，空气中弥漫着紧张的性吸引力，接下来发生的事情是这样的。那么，谢谢你的晚餐，很棒。好的。
We should do this again. Would you like to come upstairs for some coffee? Oh, no, thank you. I can't drink coffee late at night. It keeps me up. Oh, God. Oh, God. Oh, God.
我们应该再找时间这样。你愿意上楼喝杯咖啡吗？哦，不用了，谢谢。我深夜不能喝咖啡。它会让我睡不着。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。
So, um, okay. Okay. Good night. Yeah, take it easy. Leana, I'm not sure if you're a fan of SignFell, but what makes this clip funny is that George is actually not picking up on her intentions. I am a fan and it's a very funny clip because it captures this phenomenon that we study in psychology called indirect speech, which allows for misinterpretation of intentions. Because she's inviting George up for, quote, coffee, as opposed to asking him up more directly, it gives her plausible deniability. So if she declines the invitation, she declines the invitation, she doesn't have to feel bad or offended or lose her pride.
所以，嗯，好吧。好吧。晚安。好的，别客气。莉安，我不知道你是不是《宋飞正传》的粉丝，但这个片段搞笑的地方在于乔治实际上没有领会她的意图。我是个粉丝，这是一个非常搞笑的片段，因为它捕捉到了我们在心理学中研究的一种名为“间接言语”的现象，这种现象允许对意图进行错误解读。因为她邀请乔治上楼去喝所谓的“咖啡”，而不是更直接地邀请他上去，这就给了她合理的否认空间。因此，如果她拒绝了这个邀请，她拒绝了邀请，她就不必感到难堪、被冒犯或失去自尊。
But on the other hand, it also leaves room for just misinterpretation and miscommunication, which is what happens a lot in real life. Such miscommunications can be trivial, but they can also sometimes have life and death consequences. A police officer might have to make a split-second decision about whether a suspect is reaching into a pocket to grab a cell phone or to grab a gun. The officer has to read the other person's intentions in order to decide how to respond, and how he reads those intentions could be shaped by all manner of factors, including bias. Again, there is this question of what cues we are using to read people's intentions from their actions and what is really tricky about this problem is that we can't see into people's
但另一方面，这也为误解和沟通不良留下了空间，而这在现实生活中经常发生。这种沟通不良可能是微不足道的，但有时也可能产生生死攸关的后果。警察可能必须在电光石火之间做出决定，判断嫌疑人是将手伸进口袋去拿手机还是去拿枪。警察必须解读对方的意图才能决定如何反应，而他如何解读这些意图可能会受到各种因素的影响，包括偏见。这里再次出现了一个问题，即我们在利用什么线索通过人们的行为来解读他们的意图，而这个问题的真正棘手之处在于我们无法看穿人们的
heads, we can't observe their thoughts or their feelings, we can only observe what people do and in this case people's body movements reaching into a pocket, reaching into a glove compartment. And so that leaves room for misinterpretation and really awful consequences. So the fact that our ability to read intentions happens, you know, unconsciously, that most of us are not even aware that we are doing it, I'm wondering how much of a role that plays in our misreading of other people's intentions,
脑袋，我们无法观察他们的思想或感受，我们只能观察人们的行为——在这种情况下，是人们的身体动作，比如把手伸进口袋，把手伸进杂物箱。这就为误解和真正可怕的后果留下了空间。因此，鉴于我们解读意图的能力是无意识地发生的，你知道的，我们大多数人甚至没有意识到自己在这样做，我想知道这在我们在误读他人意图的过程中起到了多大作用，
because presumably that also is happening unconsciously. Absolutely. And there are many cases in which we don't realize that we are misreading people's intentions. In the Seinfeld clip, George realized shortly after the fact that he missed the boat on that opportunity because he didn't catch what the woman was doing, but there are many cases in which we don't catch our mistakes and we're not able to fix them after the fact. I'm wondering in your own life, Leanne,
因为据推测这也是无意识发生的。绝对是这样。在许多情况下，我们并没有意识到自己在误读别人的意图。在《宋飞正传》的那个片段中，乔治在事后不久意识到自己错失了良机，因为他没有领会那个女人在做什么，但在很多情况下，我们并没有发现自己的错误，也无法在事后进行纠正。莉安，我想知道在你的生活中，
have you noticed this happening of people failing to pick up on things, reading each other wrong? You've, I think, described during the pandemic wearing a mask as you go into some stores or other social settings, and wondering what people must think of you and what your intentions are. The pandemic is a really interesting case of intention reading and misunderstanding.
你有没有注意到过这种情况，人们没有领会别人的意思，把彼此的想法搞错了？我想你曾描述过，在大流行期间，你戴着口罩走进一些商店或其他社交场合，并想知道人们一定是如何看待你以及你的意图是什么。大流行是关于意图解读和误解的一个非常有趣的案例。
So there have definitely been instances in which I've gone into a public indoor space wearing a mask and I wonder what people think about what I'm doing. Do people think that I'm unvaccinated because I'm wearing a mask? And then I have to sort of stop and think about, well, what do I think when I see somebody wearing a mask indoors? Do I think that they're unvaccinated or do I think that they're being extra careful?
所以，确实有一些这样的实例：我戴着口罩走进公共室内空间，我想知道人们对我的行为是怎么想的。人们会因为我戴着口罩而认为我没有接种疫苗吗？然后我不得不停下来思考，嗯，当我看到有人在室内戴口罩时，我是怎么想的？我认为他们没有接种疫苗，还是认为他们格外小心？
Do I think that they're immunocompromised or if they have young children who are unvaccinated and so on and so it becomes a really interesting exercise to think about how people are reading my intentions and then how to read other people's intentions and sort of backtrack from that exercise to the other. When we see someone wearing a mask or not wearing a mask during the COVID pandemic, many of us assume we can read the minds of the people making those choices. We feel we can even read their character,
我认为他们免疫力低下，或者他们有未接种疫苗的幼儿等等，因此，思考人们是如何解读我的意图，然后又如何解读他人的意图，并从这种做法反推到另一种做法，成了一项非常有趣的练习。当我们在新冠大流行期间看到有人戴口罩或不戴口罩时，我们许多人都会自以为能够读懂做出这些选择的人的心思。我们甚至觉得能够看出他们的品格，
tell if they are good people or bad people. It turns out we do this a lot in politics. We regularly misread the intentions behind the choices of our political opponents. We see them as malevolent. Here's a political attack act from the presidential race in 1988. His revolving door prison policy gave weekend furloughs to first-degree murderers not eligible for parole, while out many committed other crimes like kidnapping and rape, in many are still at large. Now Michael DeCocca says he wants to do for America what he's done for Massachusetts. America can't afford that risk. So what I hear in the ad lian is that Michael de Caccus was intentionally allowing criminals
分辨出他们是好人还是坏人。事实证明，我们在政治上也经常这样做。我们经常误读政敌选择背后的意图。我们将他们视为心怀恶意的人。以下是1988年总统竞选中的一则政治攻击广告。他的旋转门监狱政策给不符合假释条件的谋杀犯提供周末特许休假，结果许多人犯下了绑架和强奸等其他罪行，许多人至今仍然在逃。现在迈克尔·杜卡基斯说，他想为美国做他在马萨诸塞州做过的事。美国承担不起这种风险。莉安，我从这则广告中听出的是，迈克尔·杜卡基斯故意让罪犯
to go scot free and commit more crimes. And, you know, the ad doesn't explicitly say that, but I think it leads me to that conclusion. That's right. There are many cases where because intentions are not black and white, because we can't see them, there's no clear evidence for intentions. This is a case where politicians are able to frame or reframe their opponents' intentions. However, they see fit to be able to shape other people's thoughts and feelings about others. There's this sort of ambiguity in this space.
逍遥法外并犯下更多罪行。你知道，广告里没有明确这么说，但我想它引导我得出了这个结论。没错。有很多情况下，由于意图并非非黑即白，由于我们看不见它们，因此没有关于意图的明确证据。在这种情况下，政客们能够塑造或重新塑造对手的意图。无论他们认为怎样合适，以便塑造其他人对其他人的想法和感受。这个领域存在着某种模糊性。
Politicians have the opportunity to be able to create different narratives, particularly about people's intentions. I'm wondering how much of the daily partisan rancor that we hear, not just in the United States, but in other countries, is shaped by misreading the intentions of our opponents that we're not just taking what they say and do at face value, but we're reading into it what we assume to be their intentions. A lot of times people do engage
政客们有机会创造出不同的叙事，特别是关于人们意图的叙事。我想知道，我们听到的日常党派之争（不仅在美国，在其他国家也是如此）有多少是由误读对手的意图造成的？我们不仅没有按字面意思去理解他们所说和所做的话，反而将我们臆测的他们的意图解读了进去。很多时候，人们确实会参与
in this willful misunderstanding or misinterpretation of the minds of people on the other side, but then in a lot of cases, I think this happens sort of automatically and unconsciously. We give people that we know and like the benefit of the doubt. And often those are the folks who are on our team or in our party. And we can interpret or understand those events very, very differently. So if you imagine that somebody in your party is being accused of some transgression, in your party is being accused of some transgression, you might start to seek alternative explanations for why they did what they were accused of doing, whereas if you heard the same story of somebody committing a crime on the other side, then you might automatically take that story description
这种对另一方人们心智的故意误解或曲解，但在很多情况下，我认为这是一种自动且无意识地发生的。我们对认识和喜欢的人表现出宽容。通常，那些都是我们团队里或党派中的人。我们可以用非常非常不同的方式来解释或理解这些事件。因此，如果你想象你党派中的某个人被指控犯了某种罪行，在你党派中的某个人被指控犯了某种罪行时，你可能会开始寻找替代解释，来解释他们为什么会做他们被指控的事情，而如果你听到同一故事说的是另一方的人犯罪，那么你可能会自动接受那个故事的描述，
at face value that they're guilty. Mm-hmm. You've conducted studies involving Democrats and Republicans or Israelis and Palestinians and obviously each of those groups is prone to mistreating the intentions of their opponents. What kind of a study was this and what did you find, Leah? We ran a series of studies in which we tested American Democrats and Republicans and also Palestinians and as well as the Middle East and we gave them examples of acts of aggression in both of those cases and asked our participants to attribute motives. And what we found, which is maybe not so surprising, but was very consistent across those different groups of people, was that people were more likely to attribute acts of aggression
认为他们有罪，并照单全收。嗯哼。你做过涉及民主党人和共和党人或以色列人和巴勒斯坦人的研究，显然这些群体中的每一个都容易误读对手的意图。这是一种什么样的研究，莉安，你发现了什么？我们进行了一系列研究，测试了美国的民主党人和共和党人，还有巴勒斯坦人以及中东地区的人，我们向他们提供了这两种情况下的侵略行为示例，并要求我们的参与者归因动机。我们发现的结果（可能并不是那么令人意外，但在那些不同群体的人当中非常一致）是，人们更有可能将侵略行为归因于
performed by their own group to in-group love. People are just trying to defend their own values and their own people, whereas people would attribute those same acts of aggression performed by an out-group to out-group hatred. They're doing this to retaliate. They're doing this to attack us. And so it's very interesting that we see this asymmetry in how people are attributing motives underlying the very same actions depending on whether those acts are being performed by people on our side or people on the other side. This tendency to be selective in how we read intentions extends well beyond the realm of politics. Leanne says we often interpret intentions in a way that confirms the stories we wish to tell about ourselves and others.
他们自己群体所表现出的群体内部之爱。人们只是在试图捍卫他们自己的价值观和他们自己的人民，而人们会将外部群体所表现出的同样侵略行为归因于群体外部的仇恨。他们这样做是为了报复。他们这样做是为了攻击我们。因此非常有趣的是，我们看到了这种不对称性：人们如何根据这些行为是由我们自己一方的人还是由对方的人所执行，来归因背后的动机。这种在解读意图时具有选择性的倾向远远超出了政治领域。莉安说，我们经常以一种证实我们希望讲述的关于我们自己和他人的故事的方式来解释意图。
I think we do that all the time and we do that in the ways that we interpret the intentions and actions of our friends as opposed to people we don't know or people that we know but don't like. We give our friends the benefit of the doubt. We give ourselves the benefit of the doubt. We don't want to see ourselves as bad people. We don't want to see our friends as bad people. And so again, if you encounter a friend doing something morally ambiguous, you might make up an excuse for why they did that in order to read their behaviors as fitting with your narrative of being friends. And so it's very interesting that we see this asymmetry in how people are attributing motives underlying the very same actions in very different ways depending on
我想我们一直在这样做，我们在解释朋友的意图和行为时这样做，而不是对我们不认识的人或我们认识但不喜欢的人这样做。我们对朋友给予宽容。我们对自己给予宽容。我们不想把自己看作坏人。我们不想把我们的朋友看作坏人。所以同样，如果你遇到一个朋友做了一件在道德上模棱两可的事情，你可能会为他们为什么这样做编造一个借口，以便将他们的行为解读为符合你对朋友关系的叙述。因此非常有趣的是，我们看到这种不对称性：人们如何以非常不同的方式将同一行为背后的动机归因，这取决于
whether those acts are being presented as performed by people on our side or people on the other side. You know, I'm reminded of a conversation that's coming up in a few weeks. It's part of our mind reading series and this is where the linguist Deborah Tannen, she says it can be hard to recognize someone's intentions even when you're having a conversation with them,
这些行为是被呈现为由我们自己这一边的人所执行，还是由对方那一边的人所执行。你知道的，我想起了几周后将要进行的一场对话。这是我们心智解读系列节目的一部分，语言学家黛博拉·泰伦在其中表示，即使你正在与某人进行对话，也很难识别出某人的意图，
but it's worth assuming their intentions are good because that makes for a smoother conversation. I'm wondering how you've taken the research that you've done Leanne and applied these insights in your own life. I think it's really useful for both relationships and also for ourselves to give others around as the benefit of the doubt.
但假设他们的意图是好的还是值得的，因为这会让对话更顺畅。我想知道你如何将你所做的研究以及莉安你在自己的生活中应用这些见解。我认为无论对于人际关系还是对于我们自己来说，对周围的人给予宽容都是非常有用的。
I think it makes for smoother social interactions and also for happier selves. What I've told my students is that if you have a bad interaction with someone, chances are they're not trying to offend you or insult you, maybe they're having a bad day, maybe they didn't get enough sleep. And I tell them to sort of think about insult you, maybe they're having a bad day, maybe they didn't get enough sleep.
我认为这能促成更顺畅的社交互动，也能让自我更快乐。我告诉我的学生的是，如果你和某人有了一次糟糕的互动，很有可能他们并不是故意要冒犯你或侮辱你，也许他们那天过得很糟糕，也许他们觉没睡够。我告诉他们去思考……侮辱你，也许他们那天过得很糟糕，也许他们觉没睡够。
And I tell them to sort of think about our one-on-one interactions in the same context that if we have a bad conversation, it's probably because, you know, I am feeling bad that I yelled at a kid that morning and has nothing to do with, you know, their paper or their project. And so again, we come back to this idea of giving people the benefit of the doubt and taking intentions into consideration. I also think about times when I'm on the road and I get upset when other drivers cut me off.
并且我告诉他们要在相同的背景下去思考我们的一对一互动：如果我们有了一次糟糕的对话，那可能是因为，你知道的，我因为那天早上对一个孩子大喊大叫而感到难受，这和他们的论文或项目毫无关系。所以，我们再次回到了给予人们宽容并将意图考虑在内的这个想法上。我也想到了我在路上开车时，当其他司机强行变道超车时我会感到沮丧的时刻。
And there's really nothing that I can do about it aside from give them the benefit of the doubt, because I know that when I'm the one who's speeding or cutting other people off, usually it's because my three year old in the back seat says she needs to go to the potty or because we're rushing to an event and we're late. And so to be able to extend that to other people,
除了给予他们宽容之外，真的没有什么办法可以解决，因为我知道，当我成为那个超速或强行加塞别人的人时，通常是因为我后座上三岁的孩子说她需要去上厕所，或者是因为我们要赶去参加一个活动而迟到了。因此，能够将这一点延伸到其他人身上，
both strangers and the people that we interact with on a regular basis, I think just makes for happier interactions all around. Isn't it really hard to do the lian? I feel like, even as I seek compassion and empathy from other people, it's hard for me to sort of give them the compassion and empathy that they seek. So there's a real paradox here. It's really hard. It's really hard to take that step back and think about what are the situational stresses and influences that could be leading to other people's actions, whereas it's sometimes easier to see those external pressures on our own selves and lives and interactions. And so if we're able to pause in the midst of a tricky interaction and think about what that other
无论是陌生人还是我们经常互动的人，我认为都会让周围的互动变得更加愉快。这样做不是很难吗，莉安？我觉得，即使我从其他人那里寻求同情和同理心，我也很难把他们所寻求的同情和同理心给予他们。所以这里存在一个真正的悖论。这真的很难。退一步去思考可能导致他人行动的情境压力和影响是什么，这真的很难，而有时看到我们自身、生活和互动中的那些外部压力则更容易一些。因此，如果我们能在一次棘手的互动中暂停一下，思考那个其他人
person is trying to do or not trying to do, again, that will lead to much smoother, much more positive interactions and ultimately relationships. Leanne Young is a psychologist and neuroscientist at Boston College. Leanne, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much, Shankar. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes,
正试图做什么或没有试图做什么，同样，这将带来更顺畅、更积极的互动，并最终带来更好的人际关系。莉安·杨是波士顿学院的心理学家和神经科学家。莉安，谢谢你今天参加《隐藏的心智》。非常感谢你，尚卡尔。《隐藏的心智》由隐藏心智传媒制作。我们的制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、赖恩·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯，
and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. We had voice acting today from Clara and Rose Dubois and Scarlett McNally. Say, it was an accident. It wasn't an accident. It wasn't accident. It wasn't. Our unsung heroes this week are Isaac Handley Minor and James Dungle. Isaac and James are respectively current and former graduate students of Leans. They helped her to brainstorm some of the examples she shared with us in today's episode. Thank you so much Isaac and James for your help in bringing to life the ideas that we shared today. Next week on the show, we continue our Mind Reading 2.0 series where they look at how we often draw the wrong conclusions from our social interactions
以及安德鲁·查德里克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的心智》的执行编辑。我们今天的配音演员有克拉拉和罗斯·杜布瓦以及斯卡利·麦克纳利。说吧，这是一场意外。这不是一场意外。这不是意外。这不是。我们本周的无名英雄是艾萨克·汉德利·迈纳和詹姆斯·邓格尔。艾萨克和詹姆斯分别是莉安的现任和前任研究生。他们帮助她集思广益，想出了我们在今天的节目中分享的一些例子。非常感谢艾萨克和詹姆斯帮助将我们今天分享的理念变为现实。下周的节目中，我们将继续我们的“心智解读 2.0”系列，探讨我们如何经常从社交互动中得出错误的结论，
leaving us lonelyer than we need to be. There's just so many mistakes that we fall into, these sort of social traps that lead us to be a lot more pessimistic about our social lives than kind of reality warrants. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
从而使我们比实际需要得更为孤独。我们陷入了太多的错误之中，这些可以说是社交陷阱，导致我们对自己的社交生活的悲观程度远超现实所证明的程度。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。再见。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。